c'est le vote de la dernière chance le
second tour des présidentielles Turcs
est une première dans l'histoire du pays
au consulat de Montréal des
ressortissants ont espoir qu'il
apportera le changement après 20 ans de
règne erdoğan
de Turquie soient libres et qu'elle ne
vivent plus dans la peur ce candidat du
Parti républicain du peuple a obtenu 45%
au premier tour contre 49,5% pour son
adversaire le président sortant rejet
Taipe erdouane qui pour d'autres
représentent la stabilité
est toujours meilleur
la diaspora turque représente 5% des
votes en Allemagne ou la communauté la
plus forte un million 500 000 expatriés
sont aussi appelés aux urnes
les fois insérer que la plupart des
ressortissants turcs sont en Europe on
parle en fait de l'Allemagne la France
donc dans ces pays là ils ont tendance à
voter pour perdre alors que dans les
pays comme le Canada Australie les
États-Unis le vote est plutôt contre
adorable la Turquie est à la croisée des
chemins ça risque complètement changé le
pays si l'opposition gagne c'est sûr que
la politique étrangère du pays va
changer
à l'inverse le président sortant gagne
le 28 mai les observateurs prévoient un
durcissement de ces politiques et une
détérioration de l'économie ici Charles
Dumoulin Radio-Canada Montréal